[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir la france déterminée à
poursuivre le combat contre le
terrorisme au sahel n'est pas au mali
déclarations du chef de la diplomatie
française et fière une phrase prononcée
la veille d'une rencontre entre le
président emmanuel macron et trois de
ses homologues sahélien on parlera du
retrait des troupes françaises du mali
et leur redéploiement avec notre invité
mouamadou à savadogo chercheurs sur les
questions de terrorisme à l'université
ouaga
l'ethiopie qui assouplit à l'état
d'urgence imposé en novembre après les
menaces des rebelles tigréens contre la
capitale addis abeba un assouplissement
proposé par le cabinet du premier
ministre habib ahmed validée par les
députés
et à la fin de ce journal on soufflera
les 200 bougies du liberia le pays a
célébré hier le bicentenaire de son
existence monrovia a accueilli plusieurs
dirigeants et dignitaires étrangers pour
commémorer l'arrivée il y a deux siècles
des premiers esclaves affranchis venus
des états unis
emmanuel macron va rencontrer demain
trois de ses homologues sahélien le
nigeria mohamed bazoum le tchadien
mahamat idriss deby et le mauritanien
mohamed ould raouani au programme des
discussions là sur la réorganisation de
la lutte contre le terrorisme au sahel
et le redéploiement des troupes
françaises paris a été clair cette lutte
se poursuivra mais pas au mali pour en
parler nous sommes avec mamadou savadogo
chercheurs sur les questions de sécurité
de terrorisme à l'université de ouaga à
un merci à d'être avec nous tout d'abord
le retrait des troupes françaises au
mali se précise mais il n'est pas
question pour paris d'abandonner la
lutte contre le djihadisme dans le sahel
comment voyez-vous ce redéploiement
mais si je vois sur le blâme en compte
comme une nouvelle stratégie de
tout pouvoir
est en route on baissa elle parce que la
menace entre temps s'est métastasé dans
les autres pays que sont le burkina du
niger est aujourd'hui la menace est en
train de descendre vers les pays du
littoral que sont le bénin le togo le
ghana et la côte d'ivoire où
les bailleurs comme la france on a même
des intérêts et je pense que c'est d'où
l'intérêt pour eux de ne les pas qui tu
es sahel parce que s'il quitte le sahel
etc
tous évidemment basculé dans la violence
extrémiste alors et emmanuel macron va
rencontrer je le disais trois de ses
homologues sahélien dont ahmed idriss
déby quel rôle pour jouer l'armée
tchadienne on sait que le contingent
tchadien danger 5 cl joue un rôle très
important
le comté jacquet a
l'habitude d'être le pointage est assez
robuste et un contingent qui rompu à
l'art du combat au sahel mais où surtout
on se pose encore la question est ce que
le logiciel est existant parce que ça
fait belle lurette qu'on n'entend plus
parler de cette organisation
sous-régionale et on se demande si avec
tous les problèmes qu'a et mama idrissa
audiard est ce qu'il pourra encore se
concentrer sur le sahel est d'autant
plus qu' il ya une instabilité politique
depuis généralisé et au sahel avec
trois firmes d'état qui sont allés au
pouvoir et pas de bouder d'un alors
justement va parler on va parler du
burkina faso le chef d'état major des
armées le général bourgade a annoncé
dans un tweet qu'il avait eu des
discussions avec le colonel major
burkinabè david cabret sur la
coopération entre les deux armées est ce
que le s que une aide militaire
française alors que la population
n'y semble pas tout à fait favorables au
burkina faso pourrait être acceptée
lorsqu'on se souvient d'ailleurs excusé
moi lorsqu'on se souvient notamment de
l'épisode du convoi militaire français
en fin d'année dernière
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ne faut pas
parler des militaires français il faut
pas deux opérations un des deux
partenaires et qui ont tout à fait
intérêt aujourd'hui à
collaborer c'est à dire la phrase est du
burkina parce que la france est désavoué
au mali et le burkina aussi à 12 rue
parce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui la junte
obligés d'avoir des résultats d'ici six
mois sinon la situation va se désagréger
davantage pour elle
donc je pense qu'ici nous avons affaire
à deux partenaires qui sont passés par
l'arrière
et je pense que c'est dans cette finale
que aujourd'hui nous pouvons et nous
voulons avoir engrangé des résultats
alors comment la france va-t-elle
poursuivre sa lutte contre le terrorisme
dans un contexte de tension extrême avec
le mali l'un des premiers pays concernés
là où où tout a commencé finalement est
ce que ce sera possible
oui ça c'est l'impossible si aujourd'hui
les chefs d'état salinisation
ouzou pense que il faut que nos chefs
d'états station en disant oui nous
voulons le partenaire fera en fait ou
non ne voulons pas le patineur français
il l'expliqué clairement à la population
avec les populations
le chant aussi que c'est cette décision
vient des dirigeants donc on ne peut pas
se permettre aujourd'hui de jouer au jeu
de cache cache en se servant
effectivement de cette question
combinera électorale donc et je pense
que le mali a donné clairement sa
position par apprendre la france et le
burkina est aussi en train de se
positionner par rapport à la plainte je
pense que leur est fait le niger qui n'a
pas encore donné clairement sa position
par rapport la france donc et nous
allons nous retrouver avec une situation
où c'est le mali qui sera exclue mais
aujourd'hui le mali peut pas exclure
dans cette lutte contre le tourisme et
on sera obligé de l'inclure parce que
c'est une lutte sans frontières et c'est
une lutte qui va du mali vers les autres
use alors vous dites que le mali ne peut
pas être exclue et qu'on va être obligé
de l'inclure est-ce qu'il faudra inclure
d'autres acteurs comme la russie et je
parle de l'armée régulière mais aussi du
groupe privé de mercenaires wagner dont
on dit qu'il est déjà sur le terrain au
mali
cela va dépendre de la volonté des
politiques pour moi et toutes les
entités toutes les structures toutes les
armées qui peuvent concourir à la mêlée
la stabilité et la paix au ca y est ils
sont nécessaires mais encore faut-il
qu'il ait une coordination entre foutu
qu'il y ait une entente parce que nous
avons vu qu'il ya une vingtaine d
stratégiques ont été développés au sahel
au mali et à peine de résultats par
manque de coordination et par manque de
d'entente entre les différentes forces
non aujourd'hui on a besoin de restituer
et sel est on a besoin de resituer cette
lutte en est réduit aux communes qui est
effectivement est réellement la lutte
contre le terrorisme engagée par tous
les états et pas tous les partenaires et
selon une même vision merci beaucoup
mamadou savadogo chercheurs sur les
questions de sécurité terrorisme
extrémiste à l'université ouaga un merci
beaucoup pour décryptage
direction l'ethiopie sous les députés
ont assoupli l'état d'urgence imposé en
novembre les rebelles tigre et a menacé
alors de marcher sur la capitale addis
abeba ce vote fait suite à une
proposition du cabinet du premier
ministre habib ahmed les précisions de
notre correspondante en ethiopie maria
guerre niculescu
cette levée de l'état d'urgence
intervient alors que la situation
sécuritaire s'est améliorée dans
certains endroits du pays les forces
tigréenne qui avait menacé en novembre
d'avancer vers la capitale éthiopienne
ce sont majoritairement retirée vers le
tigre et au mois de décembre l'état
d'urgence avait particulièrement impacté
des citoyens tigréens avec des milliers
d'arrestations et fouille sans procès
mon mandat d'arrêt
ganisation des droits de l'homme espère
maintenant voir une diminution des
violations des droits humains dans le
pays ainsi qu'un regain de la liberté de
la presse il est en revanche trop tôt
pour dire si la levée de l'état
d'urgence tandis que la fin du conflit
dans le nord du pays les combats se
poursuivent dans la région afar entre
les forces tigréenne et les forces
régionales à face aux tigres et une
crise humanitaire se déroule toujours à
huis clos les nerfs en ce moment pas de
combat au sur le tigre et et la
livraison des médicaments par voie
aérienne a récemment repris il ya donc
de l'espoir que les efforts de médiation
par l' union africaine ou encore les
états unis commencent à porter leurs
fruits mais il faudra voir au cours des
prochaines semaines si cela entraînera
en accord de cessez-le-feu ou des
négociations entre les parties au
conflit
normal de l'actualité en bref et en
images la république démocratique du
congo qui a décidé hier de lever le
couvre-feu sur l'étendue du territoire à
l'exception des deux provinces sous état
de siège le nord kivu et en ituri un
couvre-feu décrété en décembre 2020 pour
lutter contre la propagation du
coronavirus par ailleurs les autorités
n'imposent plus de tests qu'ovide 19 aux
voyageurs complètement vaccinés cette
manifestation qui a dégénéré au tchad
une marche dite de la dignité la justice
a été dispersé ce matin par la police à
feu gaz lacrymogènes et des tirs de
sommation ce rassemblement était à
l'appel des habitants des provinces du
mandoul et du moyen chari dans le sud du
pays où a eu lieu la semaine dernière
une tuerie qui a fait 12 morts dans un
conflit intercommunautaire
la justice française a validé mardi a
définitivement le non lieu dans
l'enquêté sur l'attentât qui a déclenché
le génocide au rwanda et annoncé la
clôture des investigations visant agathe
habyarimana la veuve du président hutu
mort dans l'attentât visant son avion le
génocide des tutsi avaient fait je vous
le rappelle huit cent mille morts en
c'était il ya deux siècles les premiers
esclaves affranchis venus des états unis
foulé le sol du liberia hier le pays a
célébré en grande pompe les 200 ans de
son existence monrovia a accueilli
plusieurs dirigeants et dignitaires
étrangers pour l'occasion scheer
lisbonne
il est temps de célébrer l'année du
retour il y a deux cents ans des
esclaves affranchis arrive ici des états
unis à l'époque monrovia s'appelle l'île
de providence des décennies plus tard le
liberia devient la première république
d'afrique deuxième république noire au
monde après haïti mais ces deux
centenaires ont été difficiles la fin du
xxème siècle marqué par la guerre civile
les libériens veulent désormais se
reconstruire
la lost in bio des bas salaires babin la
région d'aboisso 6 os et des
histogrammes à kerry pee wee soldats
diafutua
danaos le liberia de nombreuses
richesses naturelles comme des minerais
de fer et du caoutchouc mais la guerre a
détruit l'économie que les libériens
veulent relancer tout est possible
depuis que la stabilité politique est
revenu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
pour cela le libérienne compte pâques
célébrée cette année mais prévoit des
sommets d'investisseurs pour relancer
l'économie la santé et l'éducation
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition célia
karacena et merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis rester avec nous l'info continue
sur france 24
[Musique]